Speaker 1: Speaking by.
Oh, by the way, we have to talk about this.
This is going to sound.
Speaking of two justice systems, this is going
to sound like a story.
We already did.
I know you're going to say, David, it.
I know you did that story.
It is not an old story.
It happened again.
Radical, repugnant.
TRUMPIST Congressman Madison Cawthorn has
been caught with a gun at an airport again.
Now, I know you remember the story.
Or you might.
It's because it's happened multiple times.
In August of 2021, we did the story.
Madison Cawthorn tried to board a plane with
a gun because he did.
It was in his carry on.
He said, I didn't know it was in my carry
on.
That's what we call negligent gun ownership.
You don't know where the gun is.
That's not very responsible.
He had another run in with the law involving
weapons in September 20, September 21st of
2021, Madison Cawthorn brought a big knife
to a school board meeting.
Those aren't allowed in schools, but he is
not going to be charged for that either.
And now we have yet another story Congressman
Madison Cawthorn cited for a loaded gun, loaded,
loaded in his bag at an airport checkpoint.
This was this week, folks.
Madison Cawthorn was cited Tuesday for having
a gun at a security checkpoint at Charlotte
Airport.
This is the second time he's violated rules
that prohibit traveling with firearms in carry
on bags.
Cawthorn was cited for possession of a dangerous
weapon on city property and then released
authorities took possession of the loaded
gun, which is standard procedure.
According to the TSA, this happened around
9ama TSA officer spotted the gun in a bag.
The police say.
Cawthorn stated the firearm was his and he
was cooperative.
A report from Charlotte police on Twitter
says on Tuesday.
Yesterday, April 26, police officers assigned
to the airport were notified by the TSA that
a firearm was located in a bag at a security
screening checkpoint.
Responding officers identify the owner of
the bag as David Madison Cawthorn.
Cawthorn stated the firearm was his and he
was cooperative with officers.
A police report indicates officers recovered
a staccato two firearm magazine and nine millimeter
nine millimeter rounds of ammunition.
The gun was loaded.
Loaded, loaded, loaded.
So is there going to be any serious repercussion
for Madison Cawthorn?
You claim to be for law and order.
Just follow the law.
Now, how many times are you allowed to be
caught with firearms at airport security before
you get put on a no fly list?
And by the way, loaded.
It's against the law to bring on a carry on
a gun, even if it is unloaded.
This was a loaded firearm.
This is the epitome of irresponsible gun ownership.
Gun owners should know where their guns are
at all times.
If you're unaware of where your firearm is,
that is negligent gun ownership.
And number two, you should not be carrying
the firearms around loaded in this way.
I understand if you are someone who concealed
carries or open carries, your firearm is going
to be loaded.
That's sort of like the point here.
We're talking about a very different situation
where you are going, you're traveling, you're
going through airport security.
My friends who have firearms.
And again, I always I never talk about some.
A lot of times people ask about my personal
gun ownership and stuff.
I just don't talk about that.
I don't see any reason to talk about that.
But my friends who have firearms have theirs
locked unless in transit or in use.
And if you're careless with a firearm, if
you don't know where it is, if it's loaded,
when it's supposed to be unloaded, it's not
responsible gun ownership by its very definition
and we've talked about this before in the
context of there was an accidental shooting.
Well, what you mean is there was a negligent
discharge of a firearm.
You didn't mean to fire it and you fired it.
That's irresponsible.
With the very rare exception of the spontaneously
firing weapon, I know we once interviewed
a lawyer about I believe it was a Remington
rifle defect where it would sometimes quite
literally spontaneously fire.
That's, you know, 0.01% of these situations.
If the gun fires and you fired it accidentally,
that is a negligent discharge.
And it's often just said it was just it was
just an accident.
It was an it well, okay.
An accident.
We're talking about a negligent discharge
and irresponsible gun ownership.
And Madison Catherine's behavior with firearms
is extraordinarily irresponsible.
What should happen to him?
I don't know.
Airports and airport police have long had
significant discretion when this happens.
You can go on YouTube and find many examples
of people who bring a firearm or attempt to
bring it through security.
And it's not uncommon that, well, they're
cooperative and the gun is kept at the airport
until they come back or whatever.
With Madison Cawthorn, it's now become a habitual
thing.
And we're talking about loaded rather than
unloaded guns.
I don't know what should happen, but it doesn't
really seem like it's being taken seriously
by the justice system.
Let me know your thoughts.
We'll take a quick break and be right back.